hi there steve here steve kaufman today
i want to talk about output
speaking i know i always talk about the
importance of input and i believe very
much in the importance of input
but today
i want to talk about how do we get to
speak better because all of us who learn
languages are the majority of us
including myself although i talk a lot
about input my goal is to speak and to
speak well that's what i want to do
they can argue about the definitions of
fluency whatever but i want to speak
fluently i want to speak well
the so i'm going to talk i'm going to
mention maybe eight or nine points here
that i think are important first of all
in order to speak well you have to speak
a lot i think that's an important point
the languages that i speak the best are
the languages that i have spoken the
most so but it's not a matter of
speaking a lot now it's over the whole
length of time
that you spend or that you devote to
learning a language you have to have a
lot of opportunity to speak and i'll get
back to that so the first thing is to
speak well you have to speak a lot the
second point is i don't believe it
matters when you start speaking you can
start speaking early if you want to or
if you're in a situation where you need
to you're living in the country you have
to go to stores but if you don't it
doesn't matter because what really
matters is how much meaningful
conversation you have over the long haul
so what you do up front doesn't really
matter i put up a little greek
monologue the other day i don't think i
did very well i don't think i did much
better than i did two or three months
earlier it doesn't matter it doesn't
bother me i want to build up my
capability to eventually be fluent and
in the long run that means a lot of
meaningful conversation down the road
not necessarily what i can say after a
week or two or even a month
that's point number two
point number three is
the
interaction that you have to have with
the language
it's the same as as the
you know listening and reading that we
do it has to be meaningful it has to be
authentic and therefore i don't think
the amount of time we spend speaking in
a classroom
really counts that much
role playing in the classroom
or even when we're speaking to other
non-native speakers that's not the same
as being immersed in an environment with
native speakers if you have a lot of
opportunity to do that your spoken
language is going to improve a lot
okay so the fourth point i'd like to
make is if you don't have that
opportunity don't be too hard on
yourself a lot of people you know i say
i wish i could speak better and they're
very critical
very critical of their own capabilities
but they haven't if they haven't been in
a situation
where they can where they're with native
speakers or they're listening to a lot
of stuff and they're interacting with
people and in a natural environment if
they haven't been in that situation you
know sustained conversations evening
after evening things like that then of
course their language is going to be
somewhat limited not going to meet their
expectations so don't be tough on
yourself give yourself credit for what
you can do in fact
i find that people are overly critical
of their own ability in in a language
ability to speak but they sometimes tend
to
uh
overestimate their ability
to re to read and listen their
comprehension skills because i've been
in many situations where people say to
me you know i can read and listen my
comprehension is very good but i just
can't speak
reality is in many cases that they speak
not so badly
but if i ask them do you read novels
usually the answer is no they would find
it difficult to read a novel from page
from cover to cover
do you understand movies
um
you know do you understand audiobooks
and usually the answer is no so
that means that they've still got a long
way to go in their comprehension
ability
and if they did have really strong
comprehension ability in other words
they did understand movies and audio
books and they read novels then their
speaking would develop very quickly so
what that says to me is that
if you don't if you're not immersed in
the language if you're not in that
environment what you have to do is to
continue to build up your comprehension
skills through intensive listening and
reading activity
and
you know there's sort of two kinds of
listening and reading you can be
extensive or intensive extensive means
that you're covering a lot of new
material you're stimulating your mind
you're engaging with interesting content
you're discovering new vocabulary
sometimes it's hard
going and you need to do that in order
to increase your vocabulary increase
your familiarity with the language but
sometimes it's a good idea maybe 20 of
the time to do more intensive listening
to listen to the same material over and
over again listen to it read it save
words and phrases listen to it again
listen to it 10 15 20 times i find that
this builds up my capability in terms of
speaking
because when i speak i use a small
percentage of the sort of passive
vocabulary that i have so i it's a it's
a way of building up your capability to
use
you know those words that you're going
to activate so i would vary again
to prepare yourself i would vary
you know extensive listening and reading
with intensive
listening and reading and this is a way
to prepare yourself for that immersion
experience because don't forget just
going to that immersion experience is no
guarantee that you'll be able to take
advantage of it i see all the time i see
immigrants who come to canada and if
they don't have a fairly good level of
english english before they arrive they
never ever learn to speak properly so
when you are
given that immersion opportunity you
want to be prepared so obviously a lot
of listening and reading helps to
prepare you but there are other things
also that we can do
obviously the classroom speaking in the
classroom is however artificial it may
be it's one way of
improving you know your preparedness so
that you'll be able to cope with a
with a real you know
genuine interaction situation uh
conversations on skype i do that uh i
don't do a lot of it i might i don't do
it in the initial period but eventually
i might get to doing again you know
doing one or two a week and after each
discussion i get a list of the phrases
and words that i didn't use properly and
i studied those some tutors actually
record these for me which i think is
also
very good
so that's something that you can do to
uh
to prepare yourself for the immersion
experience speaking with uh other
non-native speakers and you know uh
polyglot clubs is also a way to prepare
yourself but it's not the same as that
full immersion experience with natives
other things you can do um
you can for example record yourself on
youtube as i did you can leave them
private but that can track your growth
in the language plus when you listen to
yourself it's an opportunity for you to
see where your gaps are and realize
where you need to improve because
there's no way the teacher is going to
you know correct all of your mistakes
so those are some things that you can do
to prepare yourself
writing is another way to prepare
yourself obviously for speaking because
you have more time when you're writing
you can look up
grammar rules to help you out
you can use google translate
and then continue writing so these are
all things that you can do
along with your input activities to
prepare yourself so that ultimately when
you are given that opportunity to be
immersed in the language you can take
full advantage and ultimately in order
to speak really well you do have to have
a lot of opportunity to speak in the
language and you want to be able to take
full advantage of it so there you have
it my thoughts on speaking bye for now
[Music]
you